hey what's up everybody thanks for
tuning in to another episode of that to
be talked today is Monday May 28th and
this episode is brought to you by my
fantastic sponsor El Cajon Harley Elko
and Harley is the finest harley-davidson
dealer in America
don't go anywhere else to get your
two-wheel machine head to el cajon
Harley in Southern California down by
San Diego yeah maybe you don't live
around there doesn't matter fly into the
airport my boy Greg Riley will pick you
up head over there and ride your bike
home wherever you live that's what I'm
talkin about an adventure get on two
wheels and ride across America or maybe
just ride down the street wherever you
live do not sleep get your motorcycle at
Elko and Harley all kinds of great
things going on there right now they've
got excellent selection of used bikes
they've got an amazing selection of
touring with the brand new Milwaukee
eight engine they can get you financed
also maybe you just need your motorcycle
service they got a great service
department they put together my machine
and it is rock solid man go get new
tires brakes whatever you need get ready
for Sturgis that's going to be coming up
right around the corner you want to have
your brand new machine to ride across
America to show off you want to be like
look at this [ __ ] badass screaming
Eagle Street Glide and then just [ __ ]
turn up the tunes a bit like ya know
coun
Harley follow them on Instagram Twitter
and Facebook tell them I sent you
make sure you get your motorcycle at
Elko and Harley I love these guys they
are my official sponsor of leatherby
talk and they have been sponsoring the
podcast for a year now so how great is
that El Cajon Harley
[Music]
all right here we are it is a three-day
weekend and nothing more three-day
weekend to me than rock and roll that's
the bottom line whenever I think of the
Memorial Day weekend
I think of 1983 May 28th May 29th May
30th the us festival I talked about it
every year and I just recently talked to
Nikki Sixx about it and I just can't
stop talking about it because it was so
epic and I feel like it just does not
get enough glory you know all you hear
about is Woodstock Coachella and you
know that's about it you never hear
about the us festival and there was two
of them there's one in what was it 81 or
82 and then there was the 83 but the 83
was the big one and it was doesn't get
any more massive than what was going on
out there and I hope one day they have a
full-blown documentary on it because it
was epic of course a lot of people just
talk about the metal day which was Van
Halen scorpions Judas Priest
triumph Motley Crue Ozzy with J Keeley
Quiet Riot but the other days were just
as [ __ ] epic you know The Clash day
one headline it was the last show ever
with the four original guys I was there
and day three David Bowie headline you
know how huge that is that's during the
return of the thin white duke era let's
dance
is massive also on that day was missing
persons and young little band called you
too you know so if you look at those
bills they were incredible and they'd
probably never be anything like that
again or maybe I mean you know Coachella
is pretty close but I'm talking about
just for the insanity you know back then
just throw up something in the middle of
nowhere
I mean he imagine you're like here's
here's let me give you the rundown real
quick Saturday the clash minute work
stray cats English beat flock of
seagulls
Boinga Boinga wala bhutta INXS Divinyls
next day which would be Sunday van Halen
scorpions triumph priest Ozzy Motley
Crue Quiet Riot a third day Bowie Stevie
Nicks John Cougar pretenders
missing-persons YouTube corta flash
Berlin little Stephen Joe Walsh the
insanity of this this weekend is not uh
you know like people say yeah we got
festivals now stuff but look at the
caliber of those fans the clash David
Bowie you know van Halen you -
pretenders John Cougar priests
I mean all the bands that's what was
going on back in the day it just seemed
like everyone was good you know I rented
it was almost ridiculous you're just
like I mean when you go to Coachella
there's a lot of bands you skip yeah
you're like now and I need to go to that
you know whatever but there was no
skipping a band on these day you're like
I mean just that new wave day the first
day you know you got a look at like men
at work had a huge hit on the radio
stray cats was absolutely blowing up
flock acetal seagulls you know
oing go boy go wall of Voodoo I'm on a
Mexican or radio INXS come on man I mean
all these bands have one thing in common
it's great songs and we still hear them
on the radio to this day so pretty
interesting three-day weekend rock and
roll
it was $20 a day I got all three I went
all three days there was a fourth day it
was a country day and that's what
Memorial Day weekend reminds me of just
complete rock and roll it's always
represented the kickoff of the summer
and and partying you know which is wild
let's see what else a tragic man just
seems like I'm going to be saying this
every week on my podcast we lost another
great one it seems like I'm going to be
saying that every week and that's just
part of getting old you know the Great's
go gregg allman lost him on Saturday 69
years old Gregg Allman man and as I
enter into my 50s you know and think
about how much I'm getting into the
Grateful Dead I really looked back to
the Allman Brothers was really my Ground
Zero of jam bands you know it was Allman
Brothers mother hips and then Black
Crowes and that's that that was my
introduction to jam bands was the Allman
Brothers I remember I remember being in
Novato I work construction I used to
drink at this bar after called the bit
of honey I'd go in there Gregg Allman
would be in there just like I guess late
80s it's hard it's a blur but somewhere
around there and he would be in there
just [ __ ] getting rum eat up man and
and and causing trouble the guy was a
gangster I loved him and he was a full
outlaw being like [ __ ] you guys and
there'll be all these epic stories
around Marion County Craig Ullman was
here last night in his Corvette just
[ __ ] gassed man yes and I remember the
first time I saw Greg Allman actually I
would said I believe it was new George
is when it was the old new George is the
one where the dead filled in touch of
gray not not when they redid it all and
I went there I went for some reason you
know it wasn't like I was some Greg
Allman fan or whatever it's like early
on you know and Greg Allman was playing
he comes out he's playing the b3 and
witson to stormy Monday and I was like
holy [ __ ] man
this guy is great there he is up there
you know the long blond hair just
hammering away on the b3 and immediately
I fell in love with Greg Allman I had
the same hair long straight hair I grew
out some sideburns got some [ __ ]
fried boots some bell-bottoms you know I
was like I want to be in the Allman
Brothers man and I was hooked
he immediately grabbed that live at the
Fillmore played it 1 billion times at
least and there I was on to my Greg
Allman and Allman Brothers journey I
can't even imagine what it was like to
see him back in the day with Dwayne and
and berry Oakley and you know the whole
original lineup had to be just had to be
insane to see Dwayne Allman up there
just ripping on the slide and his
brother just killing it on the b3 and
dickey betts very underrated dickey
betts
don't hear a lot about him and the
Allman Brothers but you know he wrote a
lot of the great tunes and you know of
course I fell in love with that song
Melissa and then a course whipping post
I mean that whipping post on the
Fillmore record is just unbelievable
better know better now Don Berna no no
Donna Donna LaDonna how [ __ ] great is
that band
southern rock they're a jam band they
were country that all this flavor and
like I said it was my first introduction
to jam bands and once I start seeing
them Warren Hays is in the band and they
put out that epic to to record set an
evening with the Allman Brothers and I
remember I bought the second set it was
called evening with all in by the second
set and had that song soul shine that
Warren Haynes wrote and I [ __ ] love
that song man
I love that song I was like cat and
Warren was just I mean - playing the
Allman Brothers you had to be a [ __ ]
master man you could just be some fool
and playing the Allman Brothers man you
had to be a master of your instrument
and of course the all-time best
eat a peach which I have on vinyl two
different copies I also have the
Fillmore East on vinyl
you know the reissue and the original
decade of hits it goes on and on and on
you know brothers and sisters the first
record I got that oh man
the Allman Brothers debut so great all
these all these records they put out are
just so original and so oh this is my
favorite one I forgot about this one I
own this one sunny at Stony Brook New
York 9 1971 September 1971 if you
haven't heard this one it is [ __ ]
smoking I forgot all about this I love
this one anyway I'm going to get more
into the Allman Brothers this week I
think Michael Devon and I are going to
whip up an Allman Brothers episode
because you can't just talk about him in
a 5 minute 5 minute you know intro on my
podcast it's just too iconic of a band
and we'll get into that the long live
Gregg Allman man you know he lived it
hard and and now he's gone 69 but I
don't think he would trade anything for
it that guy was an outlaw he partied he
lived it and 100% rock and roll
speaking of outlaw and 100 percent of
rock and roll my guest today is the
definition of 100% rock and roll
frontman and I'll tell you let me tell
you a little story since I played music
and and sang
if do back in the day to find a frontman
was almost impossible to find a good
frontman you know it was just it was
just you know you just settled a good
front man and a good drummer were hard
to find
guitar players were everywhere because
Eddie Van Halen and Jimmy Page and Randy
Rhoads everybody wanted to be the guitar
god but singers like myself usually it
just happened because no one else would
do it there you go
I'll sing you know and to find one that
you say oh my god that's a [ __ ]
frontman I'm talking about a frontman
that when you take out an ad looking for
a frontman you put that guy's name in
there like wanted frontman and this
would this is a typical frontman ad in a
in the like recycler in LA had a
magazine called the recycler and you
would put ads in there looking for
musicians and it was so [ __ ] funny
because they were all so cliche in the
same but it would be basically it would
run like this wanted frontman in the in
the vein of David Lee Roth Robert Plant
and who else would they mention at the
time yo Steven Tyler okay let me redo
the ad wanted frontman with chops they
would always say that with with vocal
chops we are a rock band with major
label interest looking for a lead singer
long hair and good looks a must no
fatties must have attitude and no Yoko
Ono girlfriend no druggies but we even
booze is cool let's take on the world
but that would be the [ __ ] that would
be the ad always no no druggies but we'd
booze is cool no fatties would be in
there
straight up no fatties must long hair
and good looks a must my point is if
this guy walked in my guest today
Sebastian Bach you would [ __ ] lose
your mind because you would go oh my god
we are going to be rock stars to have
this guy walk into your audition and
sing something like the youth gone wild
or a teen in life or I remember you or
quicksand Jesus or slave to the grind or
big guns you would just be like holy
[ __ ] you would pray the guy wouldn't get
snatched up by somebody else that's all
you would do man because that is how
rare a frontman is and my man today my
guest Sebastian Bach is the definition
of frontman what comes with frontman a
real frontman is the lunacy the 100% eat
sleep [ __ ] rock and roll as the great
Henry Rollins would say a man that you
look at and would think this guy could
do nothing else if he doesn't sing in a
band he will be dead that is a frontman
and that is Sebastian Bach and what
comes with that when you need and want
an excellent frontman you're also going
to get an artist which means there's not
going to be you know any way to contain
this animal and the reason I say this is
watch out what you wish for you wish for
the best frontman the lunatic the wild
man and when you get that all sudden
you're like oh no he's crazy
and you know oh but yeah that's what a
great frontman is you don't pull a tiger
out of the cage and not expect it to
[ __ ] scratch your eyes out man a wild
tiger and as a corny as that sounds
that's what a great frontman was and the
frontman is uh pretty much gone these
days
some good ones out there Jay Buchanan
from rival sons excellent front man
people that you look at and go look at
that guy he's a [ __ ] star I'm so
happy to have this guy on I grew up to
his music and I can't believe in 2017 I
got to sit down with him for over two
hours and and find out who this man is
and he's exactly who I thought he was
100% rock and roll and I can't thank him
enough for doing the podcast and all I
can say is as that look at it every day
and I see people passing away both camps
need to get it together and it look if
you were in Skid Row and you didn't want
to do it anymore like hey that was my
80s thing I would respect that that's
great there's people that have moved on
that's cool but if you're in Skid Row
and you don't have the original lineup
and they're all alive you're just you're
just cheating yourself man once you've
had the taste of the real [ __ ] the
real smashing [ __ ] it's tough to ever
not think about that so hopefully
hopefully they get it together but in
the meantime go out and see Sebastian
he's going to be out on the road in June
and celebrate this guy's amazing vocals
and his lunacy I love them and I hope
you guys all enjoy this episode before I
do get into the episode just a couple
quick things I've got a bunch of great
shows coming up June 2nd 3rd Portland
that's this weekend helium with Pauly
Shore
June 5th Denver Comedy Works with Pauly
Shore June 8 9 and 10 I'll be with Joey
Diaz at the Brea improv June 14th
through the 18th Minnesota I'm
headlining House a comedy at the Mall of
America
June 21st belly room I headline at the
Comedy Store June 26 through 27 28 and
30 I'll be at the stand in New York City
in 29th I'm headlining one night Boston
at Nick's comedy stop June 14th of 15th
albeit Grand Rapids with Bill burr Jew
oh sorry that's July 14th and 15th July
27 28 29 Toronto
Queen Elizabeth Theatre with Ian Edwards
red band and Sam Tripoli I love all you
guys
last but not least this episode is
brought to you by the great Saint Cross
jewelers if you're looking for a Rolex
don't go anywhere except for Saint cross
right here in Los Angeles this is my
secret favorite Rolex official dealer in
Koreatown these guys are an official
Rolex dealer don't buy on the grey
market get your watch from Saint cross
so you get that five-year warranty and
that peace of mind there's nothing worse
than buying a watch online and finding
out later it's fake oh yeah I saved a
couple grand but oops it's a fake Rolex
don't do that man I've been there you'll
lose sleep get yourself an official real
Rolex from Saint Cross jewelers tell
them I sent you go in and see Andy st.
cross jewelers to one three seven three
eight oh eight Oh a ask for Andy tell
them you heard about it on let to be
taught here it is
keep the candles lit happy three-day
weekend enjoy your Monday today
Sebastian Bach all right here we are
another episode will have to be talked
fantastic guests today man after a
four-year hounding mr. Sebastian Bach
yes how did you blow it they'll do I
didn't blow it today it's called letter
B ba let there be ba yeah you're right
hey that is [ __ ] good dude I just
thought of that nothing that I invented
them for dude we're at your house yes
and I love it because it's like it's
like it would be like my house you know
it's just rock and roll right that's all
that matters I you know in the last
couple years the the the vinyl
revolution has been revelatory for me
yeah and just talking to you for you too
because you know that's what I grew up
on and that's the sound that I love yeah
and that's my hobby now I go I'll
collect these albums this is my own
album here kicking and screaming yeah
yeah ah in the background and I'm Here I
am in my back I'm giving myself
clearance to be on the show musically
I'm clearing it right here you heard it
right here by the way my neighbor is
Heidi a Tammy budge oh yes for records
holding for you come gentle neighbor
yeah right next door I got here was my
landlord oh my why and then there she
doesn't like she's not the landlord
anymore now she just lives there but
yeah she's right really nice yeah
amoeba is such a great place and I love
Los Angeles because there's literally so
many record stores it's incredible right
adventure uh yeah all up and down you
know gimme gimme and Highland Park
sitting there been there no you gotta
[ __ ] go there or you gotta go there
Ventura's got two really good one oh
yeah I love that the one here I go to it
all the time pretty yeah freak beats
Panasonic yeah in Burbank
yeah rockaway rockaway records yeah
which has a lot of rare rare items and I
went in there the other day the other
guy in front of me was the dude who
killed Darth Vader in Star Wars Adam oh
wait I don't know his name but the
actors in last star wars oh yeah yeah
yeah yep in the flight
oh yeah oh how do I know this dude he
was by as much vile as he could carry
Star Wars money yes my everything you
could carry you are why those are the
guy that I was like should go ahead and
I was laughing and he was loudly I
couldn't plate and I go holy [ __ ] that's
the dude to kill Darth Vader and the guy
robbery he goes because he comes in here
all the time and I go that's cool and he
goes you know was in here yesterday and
I go who he goes I don't know have you
ever heard of Robert Plant
Oh Oh what are you talking about and
then he said two days ago Jimmy Page was
at Rockaway Records I go what the hell
are they buying it goes like obscure
blues artists yeah
Odessa someone or other yes yeah look
that's Jimmy Page man like that's all
about cool la is that the dudes in Led
Zeppelin go record shopping here I
thought you have the golden God photo
there that the Robert Plant man and so
if you know when you think about LA dude
I think about the riot house I think
about the rainbow and I think about the
forum and those days of Zeppelin playing
that is and also van Halen once they go
yeah you know that is really the essence
of LA and the doors earlier is it crazy
huh and um you know sadly this Sunday
we're going to be at the rainbow for
Mario's
memorial yeah man and he it was 93 years
here's a great live show man a great
life so you know I just hoping the
rainbow sticks around because every time
I Drive down Sunset there's a new
apartment building and it's going
straight up yep and then the rain books
I know like my you know they're tearing
down the House of Blues this week and
you know yeah the only thing left is
going to be the Comedy Store the whiskey
the Roxy and the rainbow that's it you
don't like to put in all these hotels up
but what are the people going to do
there's not going to be anything to do
they're gonna be like this used to be
great stay in your room now I don't know
what to say about that but maybe maybe
it'll stay hold on no oh hell yeah I
hope so I absolutely hope so
now dude if I forgot that roof well I'm
getting ready to go back out in the road
yeah on June I'm playing all of June the
United States who's in the band right
now who's in the band this June is what
apparently
I can't say I can't say that right now
or you can't you say the drummer is Andy
Sinisa from who was recommended to me by
my friend Adam Jones from tool oh yeah
random y-you know Adam he lives two
houses down from here are you kidding me
and we hang out all the time he's one of
my new buddies yeah yeah right right
down that's it you know he used to live
right over here behind Oil Can Harry's
and then the [ __ ] 80s was uh Adler
Steven Adler mill up behind oil can hair
is there man
all right oh yeah I remember going to
his house when Davy vane had that band
road crew
well year was that I think it was
probably nine when yeah when was he out
of GNR by 91 yeah so right around 92
problems at his house
91 yeah yeah I can't remember where it
was
yeah I hope not man I was just you know
what I forgot all about it too is when
Skid Row did that UK tour vane opened up
man that I'm from San Francisco and then
okay like why do I feel you're for
Canada no man the [ __ ] wrong with me
you're from Canada oh yeah right I dream
look well I do have very deep roots in
San Francisco yeah yeah they're gray Oh
many ways no yeah yeah anyways my dad
yeah wait okay
my grandma taught English at Pleasant
Hill intermediate for 45 years
Wow really 45 in Hill yeah but Wow
and my dad went to a Kalani's whoa
Orinda I was conceived my auntie
Margaret's house in Orinda Wow man it
was a weird conception that would be
crazy if you grew up in San Fran well I
that's where I if you read my book which
I could tell you didn't thank ya oh I
wish we was known I need the audio
version you see the audio version adds
on there okay but I go I'm playing I
tell the story in my book that the very
first roller coaster I've
I was a Big Dipper Santa Clara fast
right and that's also the day the very
day is 1975 yeah that I first saw kiss
and I didn't understand what the [ __ ] it
was and it's in my book that I'm it was
on the boardwalk oh they had like walk
right down yeah walking down a promenade
oh that that big case love in a building
yeah and they had like the Jumbo kiss
poster Wow and I was like I tell the
story I was walking my dad I go what the
[ __ ] yeah what is I don't know I don't
get what that is yeah how old are you
seven seven yeah you know everybody we
all say that kiss is the gateway to a
drug of rock and roll you know I love it
because you know with the vinyl
explosion collecting kiss vile is so
much fun yeah I mean there's a whole
Facebook page called kiss my wax and
it's literally where I spend the most
time on the internet I don't give it
it's fun yeah it's [ __ ] fun yeah it's
not about gossip or negativity or
[ __ ] it's about collecting records
yeah then what do you got and I got this
[ __ ] you I got this in Argentina well I
got this some [ __ ] Korea you [ __ ]
Sheldon it's all I was right all I got
this yeah what's your favorite kiss
record that's a tough one I love rock
and roll older I love the song take me
there's some real great because I
remember be on the on the playground
with my friends and we thought the word
said put your hand in my pocket grab
onto my rocket yeah feels so good to see
you and seal baby got to know do you
want to blow I always clean boy I don't
even know if that's the words I do you
want to go is it do you want to blow I
think because to us yeah that was
[ __ ] kick at oh yeah everything about
kiss man baby got to know do you wanna
blows we're like are you [ __ ] serious
I could I go creature for the night my
fingers justice traded her mama didn't
know she was there
know what my holy [ __ ] you go to Crete I
was like house form hell yeah
early rub out like was it so act like we
are for life you go the creatures of the
night record I love it but let's get
technical the very first pressing which
a Hal over there yeah the drums are
mixed so outrageously loud there are
subsequent pressings they like wimped it
out or turned it down in the mix Wow and
the first pressing of that you know
outrageous yeah that second round array
man I like a lot of tunes on I love
Benny Vincent to that you know when you
think might be a strong word I know I'm
what you love Benny Vince I love Germany
that's a true kiss I loved him sick
warrior on that tour the Encore hell
yeah Motley Crue open shout at the devil
I was at the San Francisco Civic I saw
that in Toronto and except open ball man
well I had not Lee and then they you
know Vinnie Vincent had the Randy Road
not old colored on going into that show
I didn't even know that ace wasn't in
the band yeah I saw the t-shirt I go
what the [ __ ] knock warrior
hahahaha we all they not have to fathom
the ankh warrior the ankh warrior God
man
yeah you know I think bad to the to the
dais man you you were on ground zero of
some of the monstrous tours of all time
well yeah I mean you look at you did the
New Jersey tour which was huge Jovi
record you know what socks though dude
well when you say that to me
yeah the first thing that comes to mind
is Chris Cornell oh and I just you know
I can't tell you that I was you know a
great friend to his right but we took
them on the Badmotorfinger tour for
three weeks which is you know a month
out of your life that's a long time it's
not that long on the road so it feels
like a long time a lot of gigs a lot of
people saws and in
during the gig we did at the Fox Theatre
in Detroit Wow
that's where we brought them there I'd
probably for the first time I don't know
for sure but that's [ __ ] shot it sure
it's brutal I swear dude it's like where
it all Stu be fun rock'n'roll supposed
to be fun it really is it's interesting
that you say that that you brought them
out because you know there's so much
weight put into that you know grunge
killed 80s rock and everything and it's
so wrong it's really that the labels
killed it because they get and oppressed
in the press I talked to Dave Grohl
about that whole thing I mean he's like
dude that was a [ __ ] press that was
the what he told me goes that was some
[ __ ] it was all in the press and
magazines to sell magazines he goes he
goes were like the same guy like we play
rock yeah we get up there and rock yeah
yeah I mean are you guys not Pentair out
on tour in our sewer and you know and
Soundgarden was on that tour - I think
we did one show all three of us Wow
I know we did I think it was and I can't
remember it was maybe Chicago we did one
shows Skid Row Pantera and Soundgarden
and uh I think a dime bag yeah I made a
Chris Cornell yeah it's brutal now I
mean I'm you know it's just the mood I'm
in right now yeah well I mean I I'm so
glad for that one
ah it's so weird that you get so
affected by a musician dying it's like
not you know you don't know them that
greater they're not in your family but
when you listen to someone's music for
decades yeah it does it feels like the
part of your family
I'm saying it in a weird what really
weird way well better than your family
because you're weird barely is access
yeah exactly yeah I mean I'm not I just
joke about that
that's how art is there man you get you
fallen low yeah yeah no that's not a
Grateful Dead movie yesterday and it's a
four-hour documentary and even if you're
not into the dead you got it
go check this out because you realized
the weight that was all put on Jerry
Garcia man like he's the Messiah he's
the God you know and and he couldn't
even leave his [ __ ] hotel room man
after a while that just is brutal well
you know that reminds me of the Eagles
documentary yes true the Eagles loved it
and right as I was getting into that and
like joe walsh in that thing like I
flipped on how cool he was and I bought
his whole catalog got into that then
Glenn Frey drop dead yeah I know that
was and I could have seen them at the
Forum and I was doing something like a
[ __ ] idiot
ah oh it's like right before he died I
was like I'll see you next time there's
not an X it's not next time I do miss
all the gun and buddy yeah and when
people say hey I see you're coming to
town but I'll catch you next time I'm
like you don't know there's a few things
you could be dead or there won't be a
next time because you didn't come out
and there was enough people now the club
lone pair you know there's the white
elephant in the room yeah I did that's
some real [ __ ] right some real [ __ ] it's
it's a it's an interesting thing and
you've been playing music all your lives
since what you're like 14 15 years old
yeah and you know how old are you now
I'm 51 49 49 you're gonna be 50 coming
up my next birthday is fifty yeah wow
man that is crazy
life is short right oh yeah short it is
short it's shorter than you think yeah
it's short but I still can't remember 20
years ago yeah you know two rooms well
you know in my booklet I put out I told
a lot of stories from that time that you
could remember if it's quiet enough and
there's nobody in the house yeah and you
know I'm really concentrating yes I can
remember yeah a lot of it it's what but
then again I'm I remember it from my
perspective
yeah I'm sure I'm sure of one of the
other guys in Skid Row wrote a book it
would be you know different than watch
movies that's why the dirt was great yes
poor guy
the same page well no that ain't how it
happened here's how that is you know
that would require like communication
yeah but you know we were talking about
putting a reunion together but we
couldn't even handle like a group text
that's incredible
that's like after a couple texts [ __ ]
jizz misery how does the sex how does
the text come on can we get in the
[ __ ] room yeah no that's out of the
question how does the text art hey it's
me and Rachel Zoe's hair how does it
start
yeah a modernist name names okay lord
knows yes enough of a mess yeah yeah
yeah but um hey we want your meow you
know we want to talk about maybe get
some getting back in the same room
together
yep you know let's let you know let's
let people work let's see if we can do
this right on this is going to be simple
man yep it'll be great and then I'll
read on blabbermouth you know the singer
of dragonforce is the guy and then I'll
text what the [ __ ] up man yeah really
like yeah yeah what's it what happened
with this owner what I wanted to your
manager call my manager so then their
manager won't talk to me and they won't
talk to my guy so what the [ __ ] going
on and then and then there's gigs booked
like there's we had gigs okay I'd like a
whole tour Wow
this summer at all those you know
rocking the rain yeah it's all gonna
happen but then it just didn't happen
for you'd have to do an interview with
those guys yeah but as we said
everybody's dying so what's up yeah it
makes sense
how long what do you want doing you're
in heaven you're a van Halen desert just
separate buses walk on you know it's too
simple for me to even say no way like I
don't I don't understand I don't know
what the fight is about yeah yeah I
tried to figure out what it was about -
as I was reading and reading and reading
and and you know of course it's the
infamous you booked this kiss gig okay I
know right and I 196 how could you there
have to be some other [ __ ] right like
how could it be that well you know I I
know that I've said rotten [ __ ] of
course but the thing is I'm only a human
being and another thing is part of my
sense of humor is like yeah I'll tell it
I'll say something funny that I think's
funny that they'll take not funny yeah
you know you know yeah I mean that's
crazy I could go into more detail but I
don't know if I should but I don't know
thank you what no for real though I'm
just trying to figure it out because if
when you look at it it makes no I don't
uh
the last contact I have is oh they did a
gig down in Texas Skid Row opening up
for Tiffany Tiffany and I I didn't think
it was true cuz somebody sent me a
poster on Twitter right and um I could I
thought it was fake yeah as it was a
tease night
Tiffany flavor flav and skid row with
the Skid Row logo on there I go this is
not true yeah so I sent it to any
trailer that's [ __ ] yeah so then I
did a gig in Jersey and this guy came up
backstage goes hey I'm Rachel's best
friend I go dude please can you ask him
what the [ __ ] is up with this yeah yeah
yeah then the next morning I woke up and
it was like you know just how you're
ripping me apart and talking to my
friends and I go out dude I'm just
[ __ ] asking a lot like I'm just yeah
this true is this not true can I'm not
just [ __ ] I'm not ripping anybody
apart yeah I'm like are you guys opening
for Tiffany like it's a question yeah
that I could maybe ask being that you
know when people see the Skid Row logo
most of them think I'm gonna be there
yeah so maybe that's something I could
maybe address yeah yeah that was the
last contact I have with them
I'll open a per ticket if now that's
Crillon is as when you think about in 96
where they said we don't open per kiss
we're [ __ ] big here I mean and now
they're open for Tiffany I mean I don't
know you know it's you know this is all
happening at the time of the Guns
N'Roses reunion where I'm jamming on
stage with Guns N'Roses we could
probably maybe do a gig with them I
truly thought that was going to go down
really well I thought that would be
curly gonna go down but that again that
would require the completion of a group
text an ass [ __ ] way too crazy like
playing agreeing there on a thread of a
text I think I impossible I think you
are like the monster frontman and and
and eventually people like him or the
band or like oh man we can't take that
but that's what you want a frontman
dangerous insane an animal right they
take success like what the [ __ ] look at
my house yeah I live right I do very
well yeah and I pick and choose what the
[ __ ] I want to do yeah I'm lucky to be
able to do that it's but you know I just
look at the clock it's crazy I look at
the time and you can still sing the [ __ ]
well now that I live in LA I have a la
band going you know I'm rehearsing all
the time like last night so that's the
way we always used to get good instead
of having a band where you're flying in
musicians from all over the country
right
getting them hotels and plane flights
yeah that ends no chemistry well no you
know warming it up it's almost like a
business right like that where is if you
have a band like that you all live close
to each other
and you were hers I mean you write you
can record right like that's like a real
band yeah I don't seems crazy to people
but for the last 20 years I've been
flying people all over the [ __ ] world
every time I want to do something yeah
and I'm like dude like I want to
rehearse I want to yeah maybe you don't
need to rehearse what I do yeah I like
to rehearse
I have I do I like it I get my pipes
blowing up yeah that's right it's it's
it's interesting it's tough it's tough
not to talk to you without talking about
Skid Row because it was such a big part
of my life growing up it was such a
major [ __ ] band you know I mean it
was absolutely I remember the day that
the first record comes out no way oh
yeah and then I'm with a couple buddies
also the bullet boys record came out
yeah yeah so that we're in the car yeah
and I said [ __ ] bullet boys you're going
to sell way more than skid row and the
guy and my buddy goes well I was just
thinking like but this thing is like you
know what I mean it seemed to be all
over instantly and then my buddy goes no
way man Skid Row's going to crush them
and in a year later yes pay up
[ __ ] and I was like wow I'll
gladly tell your buddy noses up I know
or something I'm just looking at fact a
Warner Brothers was a machine you know
it I mean if you're old Warner Roman
temple Yeah right and there was like
video oh yeah Yeller it was the new van
Halen sounded so much like that yeah and
they were great you know I love that
song but then eventually you know you
had it ballad that is just going to say
you had what you need man you gotta have
the rocker like big guns to get the
dudes in but then you had a teen in life
and it's [ __ ] over with man you know
what's [ __ ] crazy
do you know that like iTunes has a chart
top-selling metal songs yeah I remember
you is in the top five like yesterday
I'm not making this out how are you like
a nurse and man this is of this is of
all the songs that everybody around the
world is buying today right on [ __ ]
iTunes metal I remember he's like number
four why it's in the top five like that
in 2017 like three days ago somebody
sick oh dude look at this I go one
Wow I understand man yeah Iram yeah so
even though that is lasting the test of
time protects incredible
now now think of all the songs that have
come out and you gotta help us in on
that you got from Jovi well there's a
lot of different levels and types so
publishing yeah yeah performance right
angles always I got I I get it I get a
piece of that [ __ ] Wow
you wrote the lyrics on that right no
not all oh no I got yeah what'd you
write on that first record anything
um well stuff that I wrote basically
that you would know is every time the
melody goes up right into live 9:00 to
5:00 anywhere coos right all of that
[ __ ] was like can I do this here like
let me write that into the song yeah
exactly
boy run away all of those high notes so
like can I do this here that yeah do
that there yeah but I didn't realize
that I was like contributing to the
melody right I also didn't think anybody
was gonna [ __ ] really buy it really
like I didn't know that yeah and also it
was a kid what are you 18 on that yes 19
is IG something like that I love that
story man they see it like somebody sees
you had a [ __ ] wedding there's a mark
Liza's wedding singing at a [ __ ] that
wild Zakk Wylde same exact while and any
wasn't Zakk Wylde right yeah and [ __ ]
next thing you know the audition you're
in Skid Row and you guys got a record
deal and your whole [ __ ] life changes
it's got to be crazy dude I mean come on
crazy but you know all that is detailed
explicitly in the book I get it but I'm
just saying I'm just saying like music I
get your pump in your book but I'm
phenomena I'm not saying there's so much
detail yeah
then I kind of compartmentalize it's not
always on the tip of my brain yeah but
it's all in that yeah but I don't really
have anything else to compare it to you
you only have one life all I know is
that I'm
in the in the ever since the book came
out I've had legal stuff going on which
has like really made it very difficult
for me to work right now really some
legal stuff having to do with my past
like what I can't I don't I don't really
want to go into so much but I have to
take care of some legal things in order
to be I'm going through just really hard
[ __ ] legally right now Wow and if the
fans like why isn't he on Twitter all
the time or whatever I'm just dealing
with some life [ __ ] that is [ __ ]
miserable
and it all having to be the very day
that my book came out the day I was it
from something in the book no no I got
you it was from like it just has it's
like Alamo like the government all stuff
like that like child support like that I
you know if you read a Chris Rock
interview yeah I got really I know what
to say or who's the other guy going
through that Lopez or the right they did
he's there I could give a shittier
interview than Chris Rock about what my
life is like we're ex-wife I have to go
through stuff and it all happened the
day that my book came out I was walking
to Kennedy the chick on Fox News live to
go live on television
yeah right yep day my book came out and
I'm walking to the thing and I get this
news on my phone yeah that would drop
people to their knees or make guys jump
off a [ __ ] building Wow other guys I
go I can't [ __ ] and do this interview
and it's all live and everybody you have
to do this interview oh I could never
watch it but it was the hardest thing I
think I've ever had to do in rock oh sit
there and just go and just
compartmentalize like I never had to Wow
not like break the [ __ ] down right on
live television that's great and then I
and then I had to go to Rolling Stone
after I couldn't go I I literally
couldn't go to Rolling Stone okay that's
how [ __ ] up this was Wow
and I'm dealing with this every day and
I'm just saying if the fans like where's
his new record whatever I'm going
through [ __ ] right now I can't I can't I
have to deal with this life stuff that's
[ __ ] staggering it's just
unbelievable other guys my age that have
gone through divorce like Willie Nelson
I've heard him do interviews yeah and he
goes have you ever been through divorce
and because if you have you know it's
it's not it's [ __ ] misery it's rough
it's all about the lawyers turn ain't
about the PIA doesn't seem to ever end
yeah yeah I mean I'm happily married now
this is five years ago six [ __ ] years
ago and it's worse now than it ever was
and it's like I don't know how guys out
there that go through this [ __ ] deal
with this [ __ ] you're I just drank and
smoked and I just drink it there's a
period where you quit drinking yeah that
didn't work out so good to me that
seemed like such a setup man when you're
doing I was trying to I'm not trying to
do the whole oh oh super great island is
room that was just like so I was [ __ ]
misery I remember flying back because
they're all like drinking wine they're
like so Sebastian your dad just died how
does it feel
yeah [ __ ] do you mean how does it feel
yeah how the [ __ ] would it feel to you
and that's something really was guys
crazy yeah yeah Oh what I learned on
that show is that a little drinking goes
a long way when you're shooting a
television program yeah those if you
don't need to have to cut it out what
kind of just a little bit you have to
keep showing it in the key spots it's
all drinking again please drink it again
and the editors all like I love it have
another one I was talking to these
editors and they go I can make this show
go any way I want like a [ __ ] I could
paint like a pink Sebastian
dick I get paid [ __ ] the neighbor
come in here whatever you know well you
know I remember flying home because it
was a two-weeks shoes yeah I know that
wasn't so bad it's going to be cool
because it was actually fun doing it
right
was it fun watching it but I remember
flying home go it's going to be [ __ ]
great I go two weeks I only cried once
when the guy was asking me about my dead
father yeah
then I then I get home I put on the TV
me crying about my dead father is the
commercial for the show it's on like
every out oh my [ __ ] I go I
can't even believe this is a verdict Wow
but you know I mean I remember being in
that house saying okay we're having
dinner what time is it six o'clock
okay cool so there was always wine and
beers in there for whoever wanted them
Scotty in with drink beers yep
but I start drinking wine about 5:00
p.m.
yeah and then for some reason dinner
kind of would like never really show up
like oh that was all right for you to
York
wait for you to get drunk where's
[ __ ] deer it's common oh they set you
up dude [ __ ] he's up they set you up
blinded they say you're up dude that was
a long time ago but it is available on
youtube if you want to check out the
tragedy cuz I'm so Cooper grew whatever
girl supergroup well it's a group super
few really teeny goddesses or entertain
weekly super group well it's a group
dude like [ __ ] sandwich
Jarrett ox of Ted Nugent at all you know
not since you not know he yeah he says
rotten [ __ ] about me on bladder mouth or
whatever but oh my god I can do gravure
mouth I know you know I like where well
they do but as years go on I realized
that what they really like to do is
start fight
yeah that's what they love well that
draws stay well in yeah but a good sell
advertise oh but it's not what musics
about I know you got nothing you have to
tell me like yeah you didn't hear Jimi
Hendrix [ __ ] up Derrick glasses ass the
other day when did you [ __ ] hear that
show nope nope but UH one of my favorite
because like I mean they've had me in
quarrels and musicians but nothing ever
topped the headline Bach slams [ __ ]
sweet that was the best headline in the
history of blabbermouth wait again box
slams barfi sweet [ __ ] right he does
every [ __ ] night good that's what I
do well what was the story about I'll
leave that up to you you can go google
it okay
I like a gallon I like the blabbermouth
but they only took like five bands yeah
Cory Taylor yeah uh Vinnie Vincent once
in a while yeah they do like warriors
yeah uncle know that it's like Wars
they're always riding Lars his ass like
ours ours are and then they'll get this
you know till Anselmo yaps on always on
him always on him and then Sebastian you
know you know I've been out of the
public since that incident but girl
getting back into the scene now
it's good man it's good it was great to
see you at the at the comedy show of a
street man I love coming down there it's
so fun to have you there man it is thank
you for having me there and the 80s were
you big on comedy we ended I kicked ass
on guys one of my favorite things ever
is sctv oh yeah I collect all that rebel
on every episode that's a very unique
humor yeah one of my favorite comedy
things in the 80s was Eddie Murphy
oh yeah delirious absolutely
absolutely but I hadn't seen it in
decades when it they put it out on DVD
yeah
so I said to my son I go you guys gotta
see this man this is hilarious yeah
and it's like you put it on yeah and
he's like you know they don't get the
rub Gordon they pulled out his own are
out of my ass you have to get the
references but like words that you can't
say I'm about to say one of the things
and I don't want it oh yeah yeah yeah
cause we're in two different hand yes
different time man so I put it in for
one second for my kids I like for them
what were we watching Magma's [ __ ] I
know what a hardcore answer yes it's
such a different air do you have a hard
time dealing with the air now the PC era
do you think uh is it strange on you all
the Internet's not PC right you're right
there so I mean you know they have this
whole thing on blabber valves in the
comment section right which is pure
[ __ ] misery Oh God so sometimes you
know I'll go in there and all I'll just
turn it into a [ __ ] show under a
fingernail undermining under your neck
mark and everything really like meet me
at [ __ ] chick-fil-a at [ __ ] 2:30
p.m. Sunset Boulevard no [ __ ] well I'm
just like here's the medium yeah what do
you do with this if you just read this
[ __ ] how's about I [ __ ] respond to
this [ __ ]
hey I don't do that too much I mean I
love you so outlawed
you've always been out long well we're
never more than now never bored no way
dude I mean in the aiding the [ __ ] I've
gone through is very hard to deal with
but uh there was no one more [ __ ]
outlaw than you man there was always in
trouble but that's what a great frontman
was right well we I was raised to think
that you know rock stars can do what
they want one of my friends now is Fred
Durst yeah from there I know Fred quite
well and he's a great guy yeah I did a
movie with him you did yeah yeah he did
he directed the long shots with Ice Cube
and threw me in the movie
and an old friend of mine but go ahead
his uh he's got jazz night and added
rage of Collider how it is great I went
there is really good yeah but um he had
that whole incident where he did
Woodstock yeah and and you know they
burned place down ripped it apart and I
remember watching that at MTV you
talking about being an outlaw all I
[ __ ] saw was a band coming on stage
kick it as much ass as they could
yeah that's what we always did and like
they did it so hard that it was [ __ ]
mayhem yeah but I don't think that's the
band's fault I mean if people respond in
a way or if some people use it or axel
is it out absolutely I don't think I
don't
I think it's more of the public's
perception a lot of the time because you
know Fred Durst could not be more of a
mellow cool dude he's not out for no
trouble you know but the public wanted
some trouble that night yeah and I've
been in some situations where this crowd
is just mental yeah yeah that's a hard
thing to control and you can make that
go anyway like a reality show why don't
you want to whip them up or you know
that means you really can you really can
because we're in the band when the when
the band is on fire and they're at a
point in their career huge and the crowd
is there and they want to get rid of
some angst and rage you can turn that on
you know or you can sort of industry and
I was live like yeah that's what it is
it's always touring it's only there's no
record sales anymore so yeah you know I
really think that radio has a lot to do
with that because they don't like it's
all play the same [ __ ] all the time yeah
you know when Skid Row started was like
you put a record out a new record they
played a new record you do interviews
about it you'd go on tour about you know
yep but people still love new records
they see the videos on YouTube and they
get millions of plays so it still gets
out there it does get out there
it is a different way and it's it but
that's that's how rock and roll was when
we were young it was only the you know a
certain few four five six people at your
school I did yes you grab around the
locker you had a patch on your jacket
you're a freak you're a weirdo yeah I
mean yeah and then you'd go to a metal
show I never want to see Judas Priest
that Halford had this [ __ ] quality
where he would I don't know what it was
but he'd make I would feel like we're
all like in this together we're all
priest fans we're all we're all
metalhead yeah we're all friends were
all buddies like I don't remember fights
at those shows
no everybody was on everybody saw yeah
that's it was us against the world I
Lizzie Borden like yeah yeah give him
the ax yeah you catch the [ __ ] [ __ ] what
about [ __ ] rob man rob halford could
be the old-time best right well you know
I'm collecting a lot of these vinyl
records yeah Judas Priest is hard to
find first pressings it is hard and I'm
always looking I always go to the
priests section and I go why why is
there never any old priests records they
go we think because you know priests is
like a party band people were like
rolling joint crash the [ __ ] on British
steel and hacking them off like oh you
always got Rush and the guy goes well
Rush fans were like meticulous like they
kept those [ __ ] albums other nur
priest what you brought those records to
parties Yeah right yeah I held that for
leather and still you know I go pointing
that makes sense actually
I saw priests on the point and tree tour
man they almost solar angels love that
song [ __ ] love that big [ __ ] is that
like a helicopter like a lighting rig
that came down they come out Rob still
in that leather and denim look you know
and I never forgot it you know and then
screaming for vengeance is the biggest
punch in the face of metal of all time
man productions all right like riding
riding on the wind riding on that
Serra and sarra dinner whose iron Oh Oh
Christine of the night Bannon the Spider
Riders
oh my god then when he does the wrong
one
[Music]
ah
Oh goddamn that is a record man that is
a [ __ ] record
you know MTV they caught lightning in
the bottle twice one was the GNR Ritz
live at the Ritz and the other one is a
priest Houston
screaming for vengeance yeah yeah that
all right one that's out on DVD yeah man
that's good Halpern and they got a new
record coming out unbelievable there's
uh their last record Redeemer of souls
yeah I saw that tour [ __ ] great songs on
that
yeah Robins Robins just a [ __ ]
warrior man I mean that guy and then I
miss KK down and the boy was that guy's
cool Ritchie Falls he's great no he's
great
I'm not knocking him I just saying boy
KK down in man when he's a rule I saw
him at the ice festival you know you
went to that hour to that I want to
interview you about that yes G yeah
there's a three-day weekend and nothing
reminds me more of rock and roll then
are they us faster you know I bet you
don't know this there's a website called
history historic archives dot-com some
that has the full press conference
oh [ __ ] with Joel Walsh Waylon Jennings
and David Lee Roth for like an hour
no she I watched it on my [ __ ] TV
like three nights ago why I got a watch
I got a watch that it's a historic
films.com or something and they just got
it on there it's David it's crazy yeah
like it's not the Beverly Hilton and
they're sitting there and Wow Joel was
there the country day was the fourth day
a lot of people don't know right yeah
because you know like them punk day was
The Clash headlined in the metal day was
Van Halen but he had the new wave day
with Bowie yeah then they had a country
tell is the next weekend Yeah right yeah
Waylon Jennings and Joe Walsh and David
Lee together funny really funny yeah you
you got this amazing eagles that's from
the long run
yeah which i think is one of the great
records that the eagles did a lot of
people they downplay the long run
live in the fast lane oh that's a that's
on Hotel California long run are you
yeah hell yeah hell yeah daddy you're
talking to an easel [ __ ] master dude
are you [ __ ] an alphabetical order
it is Wow
Oh like I just saw apatite I got two
appetites original cover and then one
other cover there it is dude life in the
fast lane brother that Rick oh yeah yeah
but you know what the long run has shoes
you know that what do doot doo doo doo
doo bam bam what you gonna do tonight no
mama that's the record right there man
yeah in the city from the Warriors
remember oh my god
SAP's got a [ __ ] great selection of a
vinyl over here in the city it's so
great on them oh yeah of course the bass
player is saying that one [ __ ] so good
yeah yeah put it on yeah yeah he's
throwing on Eagles long run right now
which is just a classic I'll describe
Sebastian's house why he's changing the
record okay he's got a lot of are these
Neil's owls are Nick Neil's those hour
he's got the incredible incredible van
Halen photos friend the one with the
studio with the beer cans and everything
at Dave's just sitting there with the
overalls and that he's got an insane
Jimmy Page from the LA forum but in his
kitchen he has the slave to the grind
[ __ ] painting are the original one
his father did it's the cover and it's
the size of a goddamned [ __ ] it was
hard to get it there I mean how big is
it son 17 feet long 99 it's incredible
we had to get pulley
and [ __ ] and ropes like on the staircase
really I can raise it in and then jam it
through the doorway and like there was
like dirt take the frame off turn
diagonal to get it in the door wow it
was nuts
well I didn't get it in here now you had
your dad paint that and then later
you're going hey I got the cover for
slave to grind or did he paint it and
why he's painting you go ahead this
could be the cover how does that happen
well I just had the wall space if you
want to know the truth no I'm saying how
did it become the cover of your [ __ ]
slave to the grind
we gave the guys in Skid Row were cool
enough to like my dad's always been
artists yeah and I said why don't we let
him do the cover and they were very like
yeah and that was very very cool of them
and so Rachel and snake sent him the
lyrics and that was what he came up with
like through reading like monkey
business Wow slay to the grind that's
amazing yeah that was a great memory of
the band a lot of people [ __ ] love
slave to the grind more than the first
record you know they call that the
classic and stuff you know because it
really was so heavier and different you
know out of nowhere I mean when you
listen to slave to the grind it's
[ __ ] molten it's something like free
wheel burner
remember when grease came out with
freewheel burn and you're like holy [ __ ]
how fast is it I mean pre that it's
except with like fast as a shark right
you know with the double yeah that is
that it fast right
but slave to the grind with the amazing
thing about it is it's super molten but
it's rock and roll at the same time you
know what I mean cuz you're coming on
it's not like your go to dog thing like
that hurts my my arrows but it's so good
thank you did it's been a long time you
know my dream someday is for us to have
some sort of communication where we
could do 180 gram vinyl version of that
record with outtakes and you know
unreleased concert footage and blah blah
blah is there any extra songs from any
of the record yeah they relapse and
tapes in this house
Wow some like big tapes of songs never
came out and Wow how many songs said
like not a lot but there's a couple yeah
that's not gonna lot that gold though in
this ryoshu look really gold as I found
the we did two versions of the quicksand
jesus video one with this artist from
New York right and it was so out there
and different that the management and
the band all hated it I didn't really
necessarily hate it but everybody else
hated it and what was it just like no
band members just a full art people is
it I can't remember the artist's name
but it it involved us with like
projections of stuff on our face or
whatever right I would seen it since 91
but I found it Wow that's no fan has
ever seen this and I found the video
because when everybody hated it they
took it out of the VHS we were in like
Florida and everybody's miserable crying
trashing the room I just took the video
and I [ __ ] took it nobody wanted it
yeah yeah that sucks
Wow and I found out like two days ago in
my garage no [ __ ] [ __ ] I brought in
sighs okay didn't it's okay that's gold
that's gold I could post that on the
internet but you don't want can I say
that for any kind of reason I would I
hope they call me soon okay what the
[ __ ] just sits in a box
there's a stoop like I hit the [ __ ] out
I mean this is stupid it out back
together right what is say can you
scream out on a blu-ray yeah roadkill
right make a blu-ray of that [ __ ] why
are they doing in there no idea because
I mean that guy he's got it there's not
even DVD of that stuff they're gonna
need some money pretty soon right
ah I don't speak for them guys but it's
just it's funny that we have a chance to
do something so you know cool yeah we're
just saying no thanks wow that's I don't
know you know let me talk yeah yeah what
let me ask you this when you go in and
do the first record and the second
record how quickly track these records
vocalize do you just go in are you just
want to take it and [ __ ] blaze it on
now
III do what most singers do which is
sing it five six times I'm incompetent
yeah that's what people but on the first
two records you were doing there right
and that's where I learned to do it like
double my voice yeah like when you
double your voice it gives you this
quality that that's really like a money
sound if you can do it exact like Ozzy
Osbourne maybe some fans don't know that
pretty much all that you hear of Ozzy is
doubled oh yeah vocals and it sounds
[ __ ] great that's great but a lot of
my stuff is to like the song sweet
little sister that's all doubled yeah
cheap mmm on the ragam machine and it
sounds huge yeah that's [ __ ] I did
one album called frameshift which is his
progressive metal record and he this
gotta produce it had a triple track
every vocal one in the middle I want to
Wow awesome sternness as much though
yeah my next record I don't want to have
a much doubling at all like I want to go
back to the roots of music like with
acoustic bass songs you know having [ __ ]
onto them but one of the songs that for
me has lasted tested time like career is
called battle at the bottle which is
this song I wrote with John Rich a lot
big and rich for that CMT thing right
right like we tell it cool do that now
Wow in the set because as I get older
the volume oh yeah it gets too much for
me I I really do it
I don't either man I don't want to
damage my ears I know man my right ear
is gone
you're not my right ear and it's no I
don't want to live yeah it was bad
hearing yeah and I love rock and roll
and I always will but if I'm doing 50
cities yeah I've got to watch out from
my [ __ ] ears you know my voice
everything I have to a lot of yeah music
yeah like a Brian Johnson right now are
saying like when we get it when we get
into
in a cab to the gig they all everybody
wants to play me as I go turn that
[ __ ] [ __ ] off I got to go on stage
exactly and blast my brains out for all
night you're going air monitors oh yeah
yeah only right so girl there's a thing
called Rev 33 this device yeah that uh
that cleans up your signal so it's you
don't have ear fatigue oh the other
night yeah I can show it to you oh my
god a hundred bucks or something it's it
cleans up your signal so when you take
them off your ears aren't you know
that's incredible and really you need
one if you if you use those absolutely
use that onstage
no but when I sang for years oh yeah I
sang until in-ear monitors came out I
was like God I wish I had him now
because sometimes I'll sing out a turn
flat because like some will be so
[ __ ] loud I can't even hear oh yeah
one time I sang with a guitar does that
for me basically and I'm a - and also if
I'm on a stage in a club where the subs
are right underneath all over it's like
a battle yeah it's like the whole show
I'm telling the fart house guy if you
turn it up too much
I [ __ ] can't hear okay what it is yeah
I can enemy's like well if I don't turn
it up another sounds wimpy yeah so it's
like the [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm the same way
because you start going like what no
sucks yeah because like you're on there
like generals gathered and you go I'm
chilling and then you hear they go well
I'm not even close I don't know how well
got you do run alright then just throw
it up singing flattening it over and put
it up there yeah [ __ ] man that is crazy
when you look at the Skid Row stuff what
what's your favorite song man [ __ ] I'm
not even close to true der it's true
I've been there I met my god I'll tell
you what I like twenty years ago I did
this Zakk Wylde had a band Lynyrd
Skynyrd and they did they went out and
did like covers you know of eagles and
Allman Brothers and stuff pre pride and
glory and my band opened I booked the
tour bought a mini tour and one night
uh I said hey I want to come out do war
pigs with you guys it he goes yeah and I
stepped onstage and he can you know I
was like holy Sh this guy's on a hundred
I mean so loud and I'm a man here I was
just singing [ __ ] the whole time I had
my worst ever gig was rock and reel
actually after we put out the kicking
and screaming record yeah the tuning of
the song kicking and screaming yeah it's
[ __ ] up it's like this weird tuning
that's not a normal tuning for a guitar
440 so I know almost save money on
guitar tech so I want to get a Brazilian
dude down there there's got to be a ton
of them
so we hire God I can't speak English oh
[ __ ] but I'm like how hard can it be you
know yeah here's the [ __ ] songs tune
them yep slight plate of the grind comes
the first time fine no problem kicking
screaming second song I got a guy named
Devin on guitar the Brazilian guy hands
them the tune guitar but it's completely
in the other tuning of it's not in are
getting and scream - yeah but we blaze
through the whole [ __ ] song yeah and
I it was the worst like actually I'm
saying that yeah but it was it in the
wrong tune so I'm on what the [ __ ]
going on yeah the guitar players going
we're all killing it and then it was
like oh no is broadcast on TV oh man
it's hot yoga like you can't control it
the only way you can control that is to
go to tapes yeah so if y'all out there
want it perfect yeah we can [ __ ] get
out there like a lot of bands and just
press play but if you want the real deal
sometimes you're going to get it
sometimes you get warts and all that's
what's great though cuz you go like man
we saw here is that at the rare up rock
and really saying can preorder my mouth
like that I don't like that but it
Romero's like that's not a good manner
what do you do I love it dude but I when
I was a Motorhead one time in Norway and
I had no clue and so it was it was so
loud yeah he does come out and saying
I'm thinking up there
and I look at let me watch [ __ ] song
is that yeah right
it is crazy people that understand when
you get on there you're like it's like a
jet engine next year some of these guys
[ __ ] drums are crazy all that snare
just hairtail your [ __ ] hat on all my
cymbals yeah we're old now
this is a really true last race you got
us talk about this when you got a guy
like Brian Johnson yeah who can't be an
ac/dc because his ears are [ __ ]
yep I mean it you know Mitchell he
wishes yet in ears I know man and I and
well another thing that happens to me
too as allergies season will come and my
right get all claw internal again I
don't know what yeah I'm in yeah you're
like what I can't [ __ ] hear the
guitar I you know I went skiing at
Mammoth Mountain yeah
and you know I'm thinking about skiing
but it got altitude sickness oh because
I didn't Appling 8y after that elevation
and I didn't realize that mammoth was
like [ __ ] the mountain way the [ __ ]
up there yeah and I find it hard as you
can [ __ ] ski by the other day I was
puking
well I projectile vomit yeah my ears
were [ __ ] and they go you got altitude
sickness I didn't even know there was
such a thing
that's crazy getting all the time out
there in Denver man my eye you know yeah
I'm up on the top of the mountain and
you know I get down I'm puking yeah it's
weird I got you know it's you are the
only guy really that had communication
with Axl all during that time right yes
that's true that's that's pretty
interesting right why didn't hear from
him till like 2006 2006 so there was one
13 years right in here viewed and hear
from him either
and you get a call one day and you're
like whoa it was a text a text and they
said hey it's acts like oh this one this
is [ __ ] which one of my friends is
being an idiot yeah course I looked at
the info said 3 100 area codes I go holy
[ __ ] so I just pressed it
yeah call yeah hello I go oh my god it's
you man yeah that was crazy that ad that
he goes they starts laughing hahaha and
I go WOW because I feared it had been a
long enough time Wow Wow
but I understand that you know
disappearing sometimes yeah I see an
interesting thing happening now on the
Internet where the biggest of the big
rock stars are not on there anymore
Yap yeah I like [ __ ] this yeah and the
guys that sell out stadiums are not
posting what they had for breakfast yeah
that shit's like kind of going out the
door because it's kind of like you need
misty s right and beyond they're just
constantly I think if you have mystique
it'll dry butts into the seat it's true
because people are if they go on if they
have you all the time like I don't need
to go to the concert I'll just watch it
on periscope right it's totally yeah
it's crazy getting more like that yeah
and also I see a new thing too and you
know I said this about Axl he's like you
know top three to me of all time but
I've said that the wisest move he did
was disappearing all that time as the KK
Howard hears of rock but that was the
wisest thing to do because you know when
you look at the the era of music it gone
another way and people were just kind of
like you know if you just want to kept
putting out records with the same guy at
all yeah it would have been just over
yeah he's kept olling yeah because even
when you guys do your third record doc
McGee's like disappear for a while
grunge is here Jeremy Marte yeah
actually we went on tour through all
that which was silly yeah that was not a
great tour yeah that's in the book as
well not trying to hide the book I feel
if you want to learn about that [ __ ]
they're all in there yeah it was funny I
was with Eddie trunk today your reer
book came out and and I was on the air
with him for a Cure Aziz all he didn't
mention me oh my
would you know the whole hey yeah yeah
yeah he didn't put me in inside 30 said
what I saw out anyway books
yeah skid-row got him back I was like
what the [ __ ] I ran to the store yeah
any trunks top essential records of all
time
I'm not [ __ ] in there it's fun it's
not too fun when you're not essential
he will be in the paper Bach there yep
you're better head that's a great all
right usually actually I didn't I didn't
I gotta say though this this is
something I haven't said yet in an
interview is that one of the most
unexpected strange to me reactions that
I got from the book a lot of people uh
contacted me via email or like Eddie a
lot of people not to say some people
were like like pissed that they weren't
in my book more wow that's right like
one singer who's like one of my heroes
yeah let me to see me and I'm like you
like okay let me address this I didn't
sit down
for four years with a list of people
that I'm gonna write about and then a
list of people that I'm not all I tried
to do was make something that you would
want to read from page one to page 450
okay yeah and it's not like you oh I
gotta put this guy in here because it's
like this is the [ __ ] story if you're
not in it it's not a I got a little read
Duff McKagan book go I'm not in it this
isn't very good
that's where that's where the people say
like this [ __ ] if I read work I might
read a book cause it's a book yeah and I
what I want to know is this interesting
to read like at all
I've known Duff for a million years I'm
not in his book I don't say book could
be a lot better if I was in it I look at
that that's pretty water like I can tell
I don't want to but it's very strange
I'm like weird
what was that fans you did with Jimmy
Chamberlin and those guys you did that
record it was called the last heart
man what was that who was in it first of
all it was Jimmy Chamberlin on drums
Kelly deal from the breeders
unbelievable yeah Jimmy Fleming from the
frogs and what was that it wasn't very
good yeah but how did that come together
an interesting experiment to see if the
worlds of rock and alternative could
come together as one and the answer is
no they cannot we put that together
I don't know so on why is Bert no
exactly
Kelly deal for the breeders I called me
out of nowhere yeah I said I'd like to
do some music with you I go why just cuz
you're like a [ __ ] bunker you know
you don't give a [ __ ] yeah I go hey I
don't know okay that's wild was weird
there's a couple of good tunes on there
it never came out right I did come out
years later oh I got you because I'm not
a big release yeah it's not one of my
favorite ones that I've done yeah there
are some interesting moments on there
what was it like singing on Broadway -
that's pretty wild right I did for
Broadway shows and and it was talking me
doing some other ones didn't happen for
a couple of reasons but I just love to
sing and I started in the church choir
when I was a little boy and that's what
Broadway reminded me of in a lot of ways
yeah it was like back even some of the
songs that I sang were some of the songs
that I sang in the church choir like
Land of Hope and Glory was the song that
dr. Jekyll got married to right and I
used to sing out as a kid so it was I
was on stage on Broadway doing like [ __ ]
but I did when I was like eight or nine
Wow
so and how many shows a week like uh dr.
Jekyll is six a week Jesus Christ was
eight a week Wow and I didn't think it
was possible to do eight shows a week so
I told the producers of Jesus Christ
Superstar I can only do six
yeah and they go Sebastian here's what
we'll pay you if you do six a week
yeah and then they go here's what we'll
pay you if you do eight and I went oh
the pipes are [ __ ] amazing I'm just
feeling so up to this cover that I could
Wow I honestly thought there's no way I
can't do right let's get into that when
you're a kid you you hear kiss of course
you see the poster on the boardwalk your
earhook what is kiss and then you start
do you buy a kiss record right away or
how do you start to write wrong dad gave
a Christmas gave me kiss alive and Ted
Nugent weekend warriors a great one at
the same time Wow for Christmas and the
imagery of both those records I love Ted
on the cover with the gun and got a
shotgun yeah that was also the pinball
machine I ever loved that me too that is
great [ __ ] great but uh yeah alive
was the first one I got and that makes
you want to be a singer cuz when I don't
know like I was a kid I was like eight
yeah I didn't I didn't think people
could be rock stars yeah started in the
church choir gotcha
my buddy Dixon Davidson rolled out to me
on his bicycle I was on my bike I was
eight he goes hey man you want to sing
in the church choir if you do you can
get paid three dollars a month and if I
get you I get an extra dollar we were
like eight is nine 1976
yeah and I call I go somebody's gonna
pay me to sing yeah yeah yeah Wow
[ __ ] peel down there yeah Godin got
in the choir Riyaz Church come we're
family
no no we're I was into getting paid to
sing that's amazing
and um I it was like I had to be there
every Tuesday every Thursday at like
5:00 p.m. or six to rehearse for a
couple hours I had to be in my Kasich
and my gown and my shoes and my right
socks and everything and ride my bike
down Sunday morning like seven or eight
to be there and sing from like 9:00 a.m.
to you know 1 p.m. Sunday so I was
really doing it
you know like in as much the reason I
have say this because it's hard for me
to find choirs for my kids yeah like
that when I lived in Jersey I was trying
to find choirs for my kids like that and
I would call Church they go we don't
have a quarter like yeah I know we do we
do that like a Christmas the only yeah
but is that weird when you were a kid
they have choirs no that's a Canadian I
think the people that like some people
would sing like a couple you know I only
went to church like 4 times and made my
skin crawl yeah you know like my mom
would go on vacation the people
babysitting me would go well we go to
church oh but no what my family doesn't
for sure so I'll stay cartoons I know I
you can't stay home all your own I go I
always do what my moms at work I'm a no
a child divorced I can handle it and I
be in shirts going crazy not I go crazy
it was so scary and weird and scary yeah
and I know I remember this blue bus
would pick us up this big blue bus and
they would sing on there you know my
guru the bonus show yeah my gosh oh
hallelujah holy [ __ ] I'm not even close
god that's so real it's so real they're
right it's tough being a singer man
because it is tough because it's kind of
like a form of magic yeah you can make
this now come out of your mouth and your
body has to be on all the time like if
you you know the AC was on or you talked
all night or you did hope or here's
what's even crazier guy like hear me
we're in our 40s right yeah go on tour
like in Europe or something you go into
a venue that's no air conditioning yeah
that's a hundred [ __ ] degrees
and yours
under the light a hexacopter yeah and
sing I rock out like like the record
you can't even [ __ ] breathe you can't
there's no air run you don't even want
to be in that room it's like doing a gig
in a sauna
yeah like here's me if you see me doing
a show in a sauna yeah
I don't do a record in a sauna no I did
it in a [ __ ] amazing studio [ __ ]
bleh they hot in those places I remember
we're seeing that Black Keys in Oh for
like I went to the corner of London to
see this band right and I go in is the
place I think it's called the garage
yeah and I go there's no [ __ ] codes
in here at all there's Crandon drinking
warm beer spilling it everywhere it's a
thousand degrees is horrible how do you
how do you perform I ok and guitars are
all out of turn cuz it's too hot you
don't want to even be the [ __ ] I know
it's so not rock and there's no toilet
like stuff like that yeah go to a gig
okay me I go I got to go to the bathroom
okay well you got to walk through the
crowd to get to the bathroom I go on so
then I'm not going to the bathroom yeah
so but most people can go to the [ __ ]
bathroom yep yeah I once went to the
bathroom guys were taking pictures of me
taking a piss and I go give me your
[ __ ] camera going to smash them
and I did and then and as curious i wait
i go the [ __ ] taking pictures
means peeing yeah a rest I don't want
that arrested [ __ ] him yeah and [ __ ] his
camera smash mash don't care you're so
gangster dude man
I can't even believe it man like you
been to a gig like that right absolutely
wait does that mean Trinidadian a miss
is me taking a [ __ ] yeah
how'd it go I get a picture of this
there's my hero he's going to the
bathroom yeah [ __ ] that this is amazing
I didn't want to see gene Simmons taking
a shot right then you're in the bathroom
with the van hey what's up dude yeah
well what's up is I'm going to the
bathroom what's up with you Presley bean
delray gone
on dude let's go man you know who you
look like you look like Timon from Fast
Times whoa that movie Fast Times Rich
every bit younger and is a good friend
of mine
it's about weed yeah Bob Romanus you
look like you kind of look like look at
America either man you should have got
your letter yes that's my son
Wow how old are you it's 40 16 you play
music no good like commercials wise man
commercials awesome got you some yes 16
you're taking me out to dinner
hahaha yes the sun's paying position
commercial money better did good Haley
it's wild man I don't even know you had
kids time I am five kids yes really
yeah Wow five kids well you should let's
talk about let's talk about some party
in here okay it's pretty safe you want
to talk about bar you can read my book
I'm sure there's a lot of partying in
there yeah I get it there is but it was
uh like did blow [ __ ] with your voice at
all because it would it would ruin my
you know it did and then sometimes it
wouldn't run which would be that weird
thing yeah yeah and it was the same as
Saks yeah sometimes I didn't even want
to think about oh yeah right on your own
I wouldn't even be thinking about it
then sometimes yeah I would get King
Kong dog whoa we're [ __ ] out like
just like a while right madman like Wow
wedding and [ __ ] it's like I don't
know you've had that experience haha
better all it was either it's like
extreme yeah if I even did like I did a
lot of blow Lots gallons you know
probably not Sebastian Bach but right up
there Rowan with blow dealers to the
girl that's the comedian scene ready
Nova rock-and-roll okay well I logged
into a comedy seven year oh okay I
played music 25 oh my god yeah but if I
just ripped a key shot a blow big dead
for this okay not
always always always gone diana coach
times where it went the other couples
but imagine that boy baby just take some
viagra but I don't like blow at all I
hate it it's an awful awful drug it is a
joke bear and I say that in my book all
the time because I tell stories but you
know there's nobody doing that [ __ ]
that's cool yeah at our age yeah you're
right you know what I mean yeah and
again to think of all the rock stars
that we've lost especially in the grunge
world which isn't really our world but
all these dudes yep you know the three
men guys are gone lame Cobain and
Cornell and I would put in Shannon hoon
in there absolutely here with lines and
died from that I tell you what Scott
Weiland yeah I got about to like major
dude well well Blind Melon yeah they
didn't really hit like the other guys
was no Blind Melon I'll tell you what no
I like that one of my favorite bands
ever you know one of their Largo deals
yeah where you had the short hair I'm
believing what is that weird video mad
some Center dude Oh [ __ ] that that
record is great and when you listen to
it now you go hey this guy was way ahead
of his time and did our podcast usually
this long I go hours yeah I like it oh
yeah you know I like it I look at it
it's like we're only here on this earth
once and I look at the podcast is like
later on down the road people go look at
this [ __ ] long-form with Sebastian
farm right into it yeah right I like
playing music in the back you know it's
like this is cool it's the first Skid
Row record I mean other sin like
bogota-colombia or something become a
zombie
Colombian version yeah you know when
you're out on the road do you fight you
yeah you look for your record yeah and
then I descend upon the store like a
locust yeah yeah yeah well there's so
many cool little mom-and-pop there is
record stores still in this country I
know where December I'm going black and
red never been oh you're going to love
I've never been
that's so there's one great one in
Portland Oregon oh yeah what's called
Ron and every week you are yeah
crossroads music okay okay it's one
record store but it has like a bunch of
different dealers so it's like five
records
oh it's like a flea market and yeah when
I horse got there I want to like the
case that Jenna go well there's not that
many goes oh no dude there's one over
there there's one over there there's one
over there there's one it's like so each
dealer has his own little store in there
wow that is mere crazy hi Wow kid role
playing for you my boy trace you guys
he's wearing a fly-on-the-wall ACDC
shirt okay
Trey say hello my father another fire
yeah how old is it Dean how are you a
comedian how old are you buddy for you
like rock and roll hey guitar did
Sebastian the dad it's so weird to see
Sebastian the dad
well hey you know yeah I'm here oh hey
yeah I'm so happy that you didn't lose
all that stuff in that flood and Jersey
is saved I like that now except the two
inch masters were they in all they
weren't in there oh okay because I read
it like the two inch masters the Skid
Row's records were in there no that's
not sure about that sir yeah whatever
music you listen to besides listen a lot
of seventies music I have Steely Dan on
it I love vocals from the 70s like like
we would Mack Plummer more obscure [ __ ]
like that like there's a singer Phoebe
Snow poetry oh yeah yeah that I listen
to that all the time Wow and there's so
many great singers from that era like
I've always been a journey fan oh God
and then I heard Sam Cooke oh yeah but I
didn't know who the [ __ ] see I didn't
know nothing about that yeah and then I
heard you know where Steve Perry kind of
learn on his name yeah so I'm gonna go
collect all that now it's like Frankie
Miller is where Rod Stewart got Hazzard
I'm going to turn you on to him I love
that's where Rod Stewart got all his
stuff man you'll love this guy I love
all the million dudes out there like
that right that we don't know that's why
I find collecting records
so fascinating because each one is a
snapshot of that time yeah you know what
I mean yeah like right now don't quite
give you that really they don't like it
you're flat it's just pick on everything
kind of sounds the same
yeah albums all sound different they do
another way that it's the whole thing
man I putting it on and committing to
one piece of music right not paying
ranch's ya know a DD and I'm learning
you know we have a vinyl appreciation
parties all the time yeah I got to come
to that the rule well I different guys
houses oh I gotta come yeah I know the
vice president of Whole Foods and he has
six thousand records wrong Santa but we
have a rule you cannot raise up stylus
until the song is over there's a lot of
people would be like okay we hear that
no no no no no no no no no yeah yeah
you're allowed to change it but not
don't you gotta let the [ __ ] song
play yeah yes because we as humans have
to force ourselves now yeah to think
like that it's true because you're like
well I know yeah no listen listen to it
I mean whereas we listen to the skid-row
record the first one here just think
about when you guys were in the studio
and you sequenced the record you
probably did about three or four
different versions of the sequences and
then you went out to your car and you
drove home from where we lived with it
for a day and you go I don't like how a
better life goes into big Gunnar well
that's why I tunes I've got a problem
with it in that with shuffle being such
a part of that right yeah and genius and
all this stuff it's like sometimes I
have to figure out how to play a record
in order yeah you're right why why why
is it like that
I hate this because the artist designed
that I like that right like some some
versions about it's like how do I do
this yeah it shouldn't be like that it's
like when they go it goes from you know
freewheel burn and you know like the
next turn you got oh here comes and they
go oh what happened
it's such a bummer right you're just
like oh hell you will know that but that
is true but sequencing is such an art
everything about making records back
then the cover the cover photo the liner
notes like whoa this guy sang
backgrounds on that the artwork like
right now I've got these sideways right
yeah but then I wanted to get these
crates because I love the artwork so
much it made flipping through it yeah I
can see the artwork yeah and that's a
lost thing that's the really original
music there's no art just up in the air
now you're saying on Chinese Democracy
how's that good at it was it down when
they're working at village recorders it
was electric lady of New York so how
does that go
that was fun though he contacts you
really has and you start talking and
then what one day says I'm record come
sing and you fly daily arted so where no
I lived in Journal at the time okay and
we were hanging out and you're hanging
out and I'm playing you're the music are
you tripping out song sorry yeah and if
I came in and saying the high harmony
and the chorus and battle was there and
she's like who you really do this yeah
it was heavy it was great night and then
he then what I did angel down I was just
joking around I go so what are you gonna
sing on my record yeah he goes when I go
what he goes where I go you gotta be
kidding me
yeah and so he came and sang on three
songs on my record too so and I'm
working very hard I'm putting my book
that records never been out on vinyl
Wow and I'm working on getting my solo
catalog put on vinyl yeah you know that
Chinese Democracy record taking of
course million years and you know many
different players and all that but there
is a crown jewel in there man and that
is the I like a lot of them cited
sympathetic yeah yeah better yeah this I
love this I love oh yeah aren't you good
tens on
the one now because that sounds like
something that would have been on
illusion right in the title track to
change them off yeah yeah yeah it's an
interesting interesting record for sure
man you know but it's a weird situation
because the public doesn't give a [ __ ]
if you ever put out another record it's
so weird I think it's because kids keep
getting introduced to rock you know
there's this handful of classic records
that if you're getting into rock and
roll yep you get exposed to these alves
ACDC back and black iron made and is so
huge Oh Carl
yeah you're big made and I've made man
number i love number the beast
I love killers yeah I love peace of mind
yeah yeah peace of mind I learned how to
sing a lot from that album where Eagles
dare ya flight of Icarus that's the old
Scrabble ation mother earth yeah no no
no no god of a vandal tap out oh yeah
down in here our crime a rule is falter
a people trips to die you warm up before
you go on how long 25 minutes 25 yeah
Mel can tell like I take like a half
hour when the voice brightens up where
do you do like whip trails maps of like
dunno now the different style yeah
that's from Ron Anderson and also this
girl Katie aggressed Oh out in Long
Island but the guy I always went to Don
Lawrence doesn't do that he has a this
style called Bel Canto but it's more
scales yeah
la la la Lele Lele be not like stuff
like that right right it's more like
that but I don't have to like hold my
tongue yeah I mastered it where I didn't
have to hold my tongue you know I have
to warm up your voice jelly
yeah you gonna take it you know you got
to let the voice kind of be the voice
and I do my Bel Canto and then after Bel
Canto I'll put on some journey some
old Steve Perry because he sang in this
high tenor like if you can do don't stop
believin at karaoke you hadn't laid that
night yeah because people [ __ ] Oh
Billy of that range pure love that highs
thing is yeah that only he really sings
like that there's not a lot of other
singers that you can find yeah that sing
like that that infinity record is the
one on there
you got wheel in the sky yeah yeah night
you know and and up against you know
Greg Rowley isn't that evolution no
infinities the first one Steve Perry so
you got like Hanuman are a ninja Mulder
whoa I've been Steve comes in on a long
summer night
you know it's like what I love that Rob
uh loving you is easy oh yeah
man ray great man you know they say ribs
he lives like right up the street from
hey Johnny but I know where he lives
have you ever seen him no I don't you
know I go running sometimes I want to go
over there and knock on his door laughs
say dude we need you we's world we do we
need you we do i I do I know is like
watching that Rock n Roll Hall of Fame
was one of the saddest things I've ever
seen I had to turn it off
yeah when he didn't sing with them it
was I couldn't want it was a punch to
the stomach likes just sad because he's
standing right there and he sang a year
ago with the eels you know he did like
three dates with the eels where he
walked on it didn't like to journey
songs and there was that whole thing of
like maybe he just can't hit the notes
or anymore but it doesn't okay let me
address that yep I don't judge a human
being on how old they are like when I
was a kid my favorites were like David
Lee Roth and [ __ ] but then Ozzy was out
then and he was out of his [ __ ] mind
yeah he would go on stage with no shirt
on fattest [ __ ] with a bald head and
nobody cared I was
Auggie's fat I don't like nobody care I
don't care I don't really care so say
some guy who's 70 can't hit the notes
that he hit when he was 20 I don't care
yeah I I want his soul I want his life
experience it's not a [ __ ] contest
it's not sports yeah it's not like well
you didn't run the sprint at the same
time you ran throw the ball hundred
yards anymore means nothing to me I go
see me Leon at the Hollywood Bowl I've
got 14 chins yeah he doesn't give a [ __ ]
ease meal old yep now yeah I don't care
I'll pay $300 to sit in that seat oh
yeah
[ __ ] get into it I get into the music
I don't judge somebody on how what age
they are I don't know like cuz you know
they're gonna die someday yeah and all
you got is what they did that's it so
that's one [ __ ] thing like I don't
listen to a rush record or a Neil Young
record before I buy it
I just [ __ ] buy it yeah I just buy it
yeah and I put it on and I get into it
because they've given me enough in life
where I respect them yeah they just to
get our chests cookie just for on the
right or [ __ ] harvest alone you should
buy his whole [ __ ] catalogue yes and
you should buy mine too out there yeah
for the first three Skid Row Records
laughs right we're listening to this
first record right now and I just heard
youth gone wild and I tell you man I
remember that video I remember the
tattoo coming up youth gone wild there
it is right there and I remember going
hey that [ __ ] can sing it was
mind-boggling Wow you know the frontman
is really an eighties thing and it's
kind of gone now well you know Robert
Plant stuff but the frontman is gone
right I gotta say that I think that the
way people record records now has a lot
to do with what you're saying because
when every voice is Pro Tools and put
through the same [ __ ] program they're
all going to sound somewhat similar when
I put on the radio these days
is there's a certain sameness because
it's also perfect yeah you're right to
really get a frontman you can't cover it
up with all this perfection and programs
and all you go well you got to [ __ ]
like Janis Joplin your imagine taking
her vocal track and putting it in Pro
Tools and making it bad because that's
what people do no it was no no it was
sound like Janice joy would not be and
it wouldn't be special enough shopping
would be signed right now she would be
fine they'd be like that's the greatest
singer like I want to grow all times she
wouldn't even be in beginning but that's
one you say there's no frontman yeah we
can't even get to them through all the
layers of [ __ ] yeah how do you even get
to them like it all sounds the same like
when I listen to this record there's no
record that sounds like this it's got
its own identity that was the [ __ ]
purpose when we started in rock every
band you had to have your own sound
remember that yeah hell yeah because
when I started in Skid Row Bon Jovi was
helping us and he's like Sebastian
sometimes you sound like Vince Neil
sometimes you sound like deal sometimes
you sound like Halfords sometimes you
sound like this guy you got a [ __ ]
figure out right now how to sound like
Sebastian Wow this album is like he
write that on yes yeah good it is true
because I was a kid yeah but sometimes
it's not like then you can hear that
there would be some right oh that sounds
lame hey it was like dude now right now
yeah I'm just got a [ __ ] figured this
out
and how'd you hear it I don't just hours
of locking myself in a room singing over
and over and Michael Wagener the
producer you know helped me a lot yeah
and he produced this and he would coach
me where he say stuff like yeah two
houses to Alfred go dado report or give
me some more of that or yeah he came up
with this album and and um when we you
know did like the demos for 18 in life
that's when I first heard my own sound
like that was my sound yeah I got it
try that song yeah well come on dude
I mean you know what I mean the serums
on it but what I want to do is you're
singing on there a lot like Bryan
Johnson I'm back in black no not sound
like I'm saying where no one's going to
buy this anyway I'm singing this today
and you go holy [ __ ] I'm 49 now I gotta
sing 80 and alive it's a monster here
yeah oh yeah I could still do but I
gotta spend like you know weeks getting
ready getting my voice ready yeah
what kind of guy was Bon Jovi back then
because he was the biggest rock star on
the point during a wine hour or no but
you know what I mean he was the biggest
I still think I will be there for you is
one of the best songs ever wrote in that
era I like the song let it rock yeah oh
yeah first of all to me it was the
balance man yeah you know I'll be there
for you these five words that's where
you when I breathe I want to when you
breathe I want to be the air for you but
I know well you know he really helped us
and brought us on the New Jersey tour
yeah exposed us to the whole planet bats
and crowd yeah yeah you know not me
that's always a crapshoot you don't you
don't know people are going to go for it
so so he helped us out yeah definitely
but was he a good dude or was it like
business or what was going on back then
because man nothing is huge that machine
he was a good dude in that I was a kid
from Toronto and nobody knew in America
whatsoever a total unknown and like you
know I lived in his house for a couple
weeks or no shirt and my son when my son
was born as a little baby came down and
stayed at Jon Bon Jovi's house so I
could you know that's pretty [ __ ]
cool so when you say is he a good dude
yeah you know there's another day that I
wrote about in my book like when I was
like I first met amigo Sebastian Quan
you brought me in his closet
yeah and literally gave me the shirt off
his back like do you like Lee you like
these I'm like yeah like try to give me
some cool clothes laughs so come on I
mean yeah you didn't have to do that
oh I'm just out here but I'm saying
looking back
I was luckier than you can I mean I was
like chosen by him yeah
out of all the front men in the world
that he knew about so yes he was a good
dude
you know that's [ __ ] great that's
pretty crazy when I think that Ben is
great man you know yeah I miss Richie
cause Richie was a big part of it I
thought you know I've got normal stuff
it's just a such a bummer I don't care I
don't care how good anybody is it's like
that's a team you know that wrote some
of the best songs go I mean you know
they were also such a powerful live band
oh my god right they had that Bruce
Springsteen New Jersey working man thing
work ethic yeah but but also the way
they came off on stage like an Semak
you're like anthems ya know so like like
Bruce yeah you know you get into Bruce I
love I do the older I yeah yeah yeah who
do you get into now that you're older
like to me I hated Bruce growing up I
couldn't stand the Grateful Dead well
when I was a little boy I didn't like
Neil Young's voice right I remember
telling my dad cause even he would hold
his arse like he'd go you can be 20 on
sugar mouth suffice to go sugar mountain
yeah well that's kind of some hillbilly
right yeah but then when my dad died the
sound of Neil Young's voice that was
like he was in there it was that
powerful it was that that might like my
brain associated his music so much was
my dad so then when he died I would
[ __ ] listen to me on records and lose
my mind the best man I mean my favorite
Neil Young is on the beach and most
people don't even know love on the beach
unbelievable see the sky about to rain
is that on that mad American stars and
bar American stars apart break I got
what way I heard some people been
talking me down
there go our names read it round up but
they don't see the happy times you live
your life in my fish hahahaha that's
great so walk on but see the sky about
to rain
[ __ ] to me Roy Neil is just a killer
man harvest is unbelievable
on the beach Zuma oh you have the box
set Wow
yeah look at this right here this is the
[ __ ] right here
so yeah you got all rust never sleeps
look at live rust man lovin everything
about Neal comes a time man welcomes
what about the record the oh [ __ ] man
let me get the name of it it's
incredible be no no the electronic one
trans dude I don't even know but I might
have lived that hopeless [ __ ] oh no
you got to get into trance because it's
like if you're into craft work you can
tell what was going on in the crash are
you guys okay I'm gonna get you in a
crowd yeah all right you know my point
is the great thing about music is here I
am now a huge Bruce fan and a dead fan
and now I can dive down that rabbit hole
and they put out so much yeah yeah and I
know I've got five ten years holy by the
way I think right dude I'm getting into
the Beach Boys yeah because there's been
growing I hate him but I was a metalhead
I wanted I just you know have here in
the [ __ ] heart head down dinging just
the harmonies are crazy
yeah right so I listen to that and the
Beatles like I wasn't my dad loved the
Beatles so much that was like dad's band
yep but now I'm [ __ ] collecting those
first pressings of that that play love
up in Vegas oh yeah go to that no I got
to see that that is not yeah he liked I
love it that I'm getting into the
Beatles hard yeah but you know I got
heavily into the Beach Boys
once I got turned on to ped sounds and
then I was like holy [ __ ] these tunes
are darkest yeah well then this is some
dark stuff dude you know speaking of
dark the dark night is what
Caravaggio is going on right now
Sebastian Suns coming in about every
five minutes and a different cover here
on costume and it is one of the funniest
podcast I've ever done it's just like
what's going on here this is my life did
yeah I got a little Batman running
around you got so lucky man you still
have your hair dude come on I know I can
see that I got that extension
I know fake a mile away it looks like
hair curtain I gotta get a color bed but
you know we can imagine Sebastian bald
you know I don't know wrong I would be
into hat your hat yeah you know I had
this idea a million years ago like um
you know nobody did this like when you
go bald
yep why not get a tattoo of hair oh
that's perfectly QWOP down here packed
like perfect like my boss got yeah what
to haul your [ __ ] head over all those
open it quickly but give you a match
yeah right just a peg why did anybody
ever and you would always be here along
perfect hair always long at just going
to give me the Sebastian hair anything I
like or you could like you don't go
Medusa I like snakes and [ __ ] they're
coming to get you was that malice yeah
that's uh that uh I don't even know who
did that
Medusa oh man I think this is a king
diamond I can't write you get in to kill
Melissa oh yeah oh yeah moment I'd be
the first to watch your funeral and I'd
be the last to me
his low voices crying basically like oh
and then it high voice is just like the
funniest thing is it I did a gig of them
in Brazil yeah chain-smoke sick I know
right not anymore you had that triple
bypass right yeah man he's like already
glow stages [ __ ] just smoke smoke it
never affected my voice or drinking you
know you know knows I rape a lot yeah
more than smoke and damping is better
yeah yeah yeah yeah baby
you get into the weed yeah the great guy
yeah Lafleur Nia yeah yeah legal it's so
strong no I enjoy it
it's so strong no right you too tense
would strain but yeah yeah it works you
ever get into mushrooms that not too
much no not that still wrong you ever
talk to kiss Gene Simmons or anybody um
Paul Stanley is good friends with my
friend Cheryl Rickson who was the lady
on the back of Rob Halfords uh
motorcycle and cream magazine this is
really yeah but I remember that back
there yeah she lives around here I lived
in her house for two years and Wow
pretty cool we had a kiss theme birthday
party for trace last month while
everybody was in kiss maker we had a
pulse failure person ater in the boots
and I saw Paul Collier last month and I
live up the street from you yeah that's
why I live right close to you so I'm in
this pizza place me and Michael Devon
yeah that's like I'm playing he's in my
band kind of oh my god Evan well you I'm
Jan I jam it in last night oh you
wouldn't even tell me he's incredible
he's so great good it is pipes oh how
about a city well we did sweet little
sister I was like oh my god singing
screaming it perfect yeah yeah yeah
Manny co-hosts his podcast with me are
like twice a month you know yeah and I
was I was like where are you last night
he's I come in the studio bro he
wouldn't tell me like I I'm going to
Texaco Street I'm going to send him a
video
right now I'm gonna hate you bad sir
let's get it right now a lot all right
here we go here video Moses with you
yeah yeah hey hey you bastard that video
yeah yeah I'm going to send it to
anybody
yeah what's up welcome with you last
night why you're not telling me man I
thought we were close because it's
trying to hold secrets a secret super
group thank you no more secrets
so you see super group up so you just
threw on slave to the grind and we were
just talking about it's super hard to
find on vinyl and that was an era where
CDs start kicking in and we're not even
really thinking about vinyl anymore
[Music]
Oh
sailu cow mr. bang a beta because the
weather's run at Rhino like a soda
buncha game gonna die no ha ha ha [ __ ]
ha ha ha ha
man much monkey business is crazy what I
could what a great record right
it is production productions massive and
it doesn't sound dated know it says [ __ ]
it you know it's like back in black does
not sound dated no that never will yeah
but there's this records that we're in
the eighties where they had those
dumbass snares there's a lot of railroad
go wrong Oh Jill Walsh record called
confessor yeah and all the drums are
fake drums and I still like it but I
would love to hear it with like a real
drummer yeah
but that big red that weird reverse
snare back there like cherry pie you
know this one's right at that audience
did it so when you see what's the cover
band those guys a seal tanzeel Panther
they it's so obvious that they even
sample it they just do the karate moves
you know but yeah you know like back in
black this record Appetite oh it sounds
[ __ ] epic it doesn't have any dated
sound oh I know what you just said you
can't tell this was mastered for vinyl
right I'm thinking vinyl yeah yeah cuz
it's pretty big they got a lot of just
listen right there yeah you got some
low-end you know because people don't
understand that when when stuff is print
out on CD and a lot of these shitty
reissues of vinyl now the labels just
they're cashing in like they just
reissued all the Pink Floyd and they
didn't do it from the analog why what's
the big point of all people who it's all
about the cyanosis and and and so you're
getting off these glass masters that
were mastered for CD which is a total
different sound you know it doesn't make
any sense it doesn't man it's crazy
that's one of the threads on the
is my wax Facebook thing if you're in
all this yeah there's arguments about
because they did the reissues from
digital right and they sound great but
why not do it from the analog and get
that sound I think because it costs
money I think maybe because those tapes
aren't in good shape well they could
bake them and retail but you know when
you to me we're talking about this when
I first got here you got to buy the
originals if they're available and a
mint copy of like appetite when I put it
on or a mint copy and Neil Young on the
beach or harvest or a mint copy of Rush
moving pictures Oh put it on your go
wall Steely Dan Oh Asia come on
I don't know album sounds like that no
I'm not like that
Steely Dan quality sounds that is just
cocaine jazz at its finest right I want
to make my dough my next record a
California record with that kind of
production yeah kind of sound that's
what I'm gonna go for you ever think
about doing a record that was a like you
know kind of singer-songwriter well my
next record is definitely gonna have
that bow of the bottle song on it and
I'm gonna you know as I get older like I
want to be able to sit down with an
acoustic guitar and just sing rap
without all the production of a loved on
so yeah because I can do that forever
well you know after for me what happened
was after 80s rock I think a lot of 80s
people they stuck in the 80s in a way of
life they didn't grow as listeners no to
me and you and I said this to Nikki Sixx
recently on a show I think a lot of
people look at music as just a time
machine back to when they were happy and
single and not married with bills and
whatever to me music was more of a way
alive so from the 80s I grow into the
grunge and then I grow into the alt
country which is Milko and Sun vault and
Ryan add
and all that stuff and and keep going
you know to where when I post stuff on
Instagram people like goddamn your music
is so eclectic it's like yeah because I
love new yeah me too it's not sports
teams no dot Dimebag said it one time
you know they go what kind of music you
like or don't like it goes I pretty much
like all kinds of music yeah because
there's not much music I don't like yeah
and it's just like I like music too like
that and it and it search silent as you
said now that you're getting into like
you know you're getting into stuff as
you get older that maybe your dad loves
ya and as oh yeah when I was young you
know I was like Metallica only [ __ ]
everything out you know I was like
that's you yeah you're like that but
then if you're true music man you go
like god I was done back then well I got
to be totally honest with you like three
years ago two years ago but I want to
get my ears check out my doctor I had
that plug clogged up thing from from
allergy yeah she has this machine it'll
suck all that [ __ ] out right yeah you
should go see this oh my god I know that
can do that Wow can [ __ ] yank that
[ __ ] out what's he do a dr. singer man
down on Beverly Hills all right it is
involved yeah but what is digital hook
something in there he's got like a
vacuum machine like oh yeah I don't like
your equilibrium is what you're all like
yeah I getting that taken out for the
first time is all right oh yeah so I go
there all the time and silly he's like
he checked out my ear my hearing and he
did the whole test he goes okay
Sebastian I can tell that you've been
playing rock and roll your whole life
because when we're on stage all the time
most musicians have a little dip in
their high-end right from years and
years there he goes but you're funny cuz
your ears are fine it goes you got no
problems whoa
but if you don't start now yeah turning
it down
yeah in ten years from now you will wish
but you did yeah and I [ __ ] what do
you told me that I wet I cried nobody
had ever said that to me and I don't I
was like you I've cracked the [ __ ] out
of my music yeah I liked it [ __ ] loud
me too and you know what feels good yeah
but you know now I don't you know what I
like now war well what what I did when I
doctor told that I'd follow his advice
[ __ ] turned it down and it did to
alter my taste in music ah in ways that
when I turned it down I heard more [ __ ]
yeah that I didn't even know like that
was in the song what I was blaring it
yeah for years then I turn it down I
hear [ __ ] that I never heard yeah you're
like what is that my speakerphone here
we go [ __ ] guys playing like congas in
the background I thought my speaker was
blown you know so that what it did is it
really made me appreciate singing and
harmonies a lot more yeah so like my
next record is going to have a lot of
harmony I love harmony oh yeah I got you
know I think Black Crowes were really a
big deal to me right then in that 80s
where they were like of course I love
the stones worship the stones but that
was older guys you know era and
everything and black crows to me were
like whoa these are you could actually
do this like black crows and Blind Melon
like you could play like kind of rootsy
rock and roll and that really got me
into that you know I mean especially the
southern harmony and the America record
you know get out where your black rose
guy uh not as well I was really a
metalhead whenever out yeah I got a pant
hair and white zombie and biohazard yeah
I was before my doctor told me to turn
it down well you know I was right there
on bull that was my point like man I saw
white zombie at the at the DNA my gang
with them before they were a big dick
god of thunder as the line lay with them
just when they're in New York bad
remember the my lie my god you know how
I got to the stage however yeah yeah
yeah jump ha ha
and Shawn the bass player she's like no
no no and drugs like no don't do that
and I [ __ ] was loaded yeah yeah on the
stage unbelievable yep estate and I went
down and I like spray my [ __ ] my wrist
uh yeah yeah ah how great was the
limelight while it was a lot of rooms in
the back yeah that were dark yeah the
library all sorts of [ __ ] oh my god what
was that what was Jersey like back then
because I was in San Francisco Bay Area
gosh not to sound like a broken record
yeah but I told us in detail my book the
very first time I ever went there yeah
so if you really want to know I get that
but I'm saying well what I say in the
book is that you could feel in 86 and 87
like Bon Jovi and little Stephen and
Bruce Springsteen that whole feeling
yeah you could literally feel downtown
driving yeah you could feel all that
like the same ways when you're on Sunset
Strip yeah you can feel Motley Crue and
all those bands and feel that [ __ ] yeah
in Jersey with the jersey music so I was
like I want some of this man I want some
of this vibe it's a cool vibe yeah yeah
yeah even even now with The Sopranos you
know when you're there time for me to
start watching that again it's so great
are you watching it again I rewatched it
like a year and a half ago and it was
just it's just mind-boggling how great
it is you know I still think greatest TV
would be all in the family love it then
you get Sopranos and then Breaking Bad
as far as love Breaking Bad yeah right
and your things also I gotta watch that
dude stranger things you watch love know
you got to get into love did time place
I'm telling those stranger things is up
there with Breaking Bad all right it's
up there all right where's being a great
show
there's also a couple other really good
shows the affair yeah watch that you
gotta watch love there's one called
divorce devote divorce with Sarah
Jessica Parker which is a good show
Wow yeah you watch a lot of TV yeah I
don't watch much I love Netflix yeah
who's your favorite comic now you watch
a lot of comedy yeah like you the first
time I saw you when you did your rock
and roll yeah comedy I was loving that
and I loved Dane Cook you're a friend
yep the Trailer Park Boys oh yeah I'm on
their shell and right they're hilarious
yeah it shot a new just shot Nathan yeah
holy [ __ ] coming out up at the marijuana
mansion
what was that like a couple blocks away
from my house marijuana mansions it's
called yeah Wow
and it's this guy that owns this
nutrient company advanced nutrients like
a billionaire with this big mansion up
there was so he shot an episode up there
with Snoop Dogg and Verne Troyer yeah
Brahm green Tom Green Greg Brady he's
fun that's funny [ __ ] ever that I was a
co-host and Tom Green's show when he'd
be on vacation a TV show for a while and
I'm going to do it you know and I I was
hanging with him and we did a he did a
greatest Tom Green episode and showed
old stuff from the ball and some of that
Tom Green stuff is so [ __ ] funny Matt
there's one where he paints a naked
chick on his dad's car and his dad gets
up to go to work and there's just this
naked ship with a vagina on the hood i
dude it's one of the funniest things
I've ever seen man
I remember when he tried to deliver
pizzas that guy yeah yeah yeah
Oh oh my god he is so funny man yes
so did not to wrap this up yeah hide my
pot good with it yeah we'll get off I
gotta tell you man I can't thank you
enough for doing the pontine delray yeah
I did I love units
III trip out so much when I I have
people on the show that were monumental
in my life I'm like oh my god this guy
was like people people can slag on an
arrow all they want and if you don't
like that error or whatever but what
they don't understand was the magnitude
of some of these concerts man they were
electric man still it still is happening
I mean I did 50 shows last year from
October to December I was juggling all
the plates in the air and then I got
stopped yeah momentarily but I'm getting
back into it and I'm gonna hit the road
hard you're gonna pray LA I don't know
when but sometimes I'll be there but I'm
you know I'm going to do my album put
out a new album jam and hit it hard it's
gonna be great thank you so much are you
honest Grammer yeah battabox yeah
oh I remember one quick thing that one
Instagram with the giant rattlesnake oh
he saw a slide I had filmed the
rattlesnake two weeks before that and me
and my buddy it was a small one you know
and I was like holy smokes you know
Beachwood Canyon and then you said look
at this snake and I was like oh man that
was cute I love running around us up in
these hills it's great right Hillier
yeah well it was great to see it I'm
looking forward to going to one of your
vinyl parties yeah you got and you're
coming yeah and and and go out there man
and throw on a Guinness Book what's the
book called again 18 in life on Skid Row
yeah give you one today I'm going to
read it alright I will read it man well
next to the toilet that's the perfect
place to read book I like to read them
on playing yeah I like this one yeah
thank you so much thanks guys for my
friend candles lit leave a review and
subscribe on iTunes
you